hallo und herzlich willkommen heute geht
es bei easyjet um das thema streiten wie
streitet man auf deutsch dafür haben wir
eingeladen emanuel von your daily german
dot com und janiszewski die toilette
da geht es schon los wir sehen jetzt
einige szenen und da könnt ihr mal sehen
wie man auf deutsch so richtig streitet
seid ihr bereit seid ja wohl los geht's
[Musik]
pass mal auf alter pass mal auf alter ja
ich entschuldige mich zumal ja aber es
waren derjenige der mich angerempelt hat
das heißt sie müssen bitte aufpassen und
auch auf andere menschen achten sie
dürfen nicht einfach mehr machen wir
heute mal da noch eine entschuldigung
verlangt heute manchmal warte mal ich
bin gerade ausgelaufen
du hast auf dein handy geguckt nein ich
habe du musst halt irgendwo hingehe
du musst gucken wo du hingehst motor ist
es nicht ein bisschen normal wenn du
musst gucken dass du dich ein bisschen
normal benimmst einfach gucken wo du
hingehst aufpassen was du sagst dann ist
alles und robbie show
[Musik]
verpiss dich hast du mich gefragt ob du
ein bild machen darf
hast du mich gefragt ob du ein bild
machen darf was ich frage dich ob du
eine erlaubnis hart hier zu
fotografieren das kann ich dir gleich
die kamera konfiszieren
bleiben wir ruhig bleibt mal ruhig
bleibt man ruhig es habe da hinten die
waren eine griechische land ganz
offensichtlich vor der linse und ab da
musst du mich fragen bist du bescheuert
bist du bescheuert
du bist reingelaufen du warst überhaupt
nicht im bild das ich dass da schon
wesentlich sobald gingen vor deiner
lebens heraus was mein alter was ist
denn mit dir los
nein ich automatisch dass ich auf mein
eigenes bild und dann brauchst du
schriftlich ist glaube ich will dein
komisches gesicht nicht auf meinem ship
haben ja tust du aber ja weil du rein
gelaufen bin
das ist unrein ich laufe immer rein ich
laufe jetzt stehe ich vor der linse ja
dann ja dann geh weg ja dann geweckt und
dann fotografiert sich in alison
krimineller du bist ein krimineller
ach ja so bescheuert krimineller du
verletzt meine kann man jetzt noch
weiterhin bitte geh weiter geh mal
weiter immer weiter was drauf schönen
guten tag hier ist hat mir ist gerade
jemand aufs auto gefahren und da ist ein
kratzer und der herr meint das wäre kein
problem
können sie bitte eine streife vorbei
schicken
wunderbar ja wir bleiben hier
vielen dank ok ich freue mich sehr dass
darauf ist immer verlass sie wenn sie
auslaufen wenn es keine leiche gibt gibt
es auch keinen mörder wenn es kein
kratzer gibt gibt es auch kein unfall
und sie nehmen wir den anspruch eine
aktion die den deutschen
steuerzahler sehr viel geld kostet nur
um sich zu beschwerden er hat mich
angriff angetippt ja es gibt keinen
kratzer es gibt gar nichts aber ich bin
trotzdem der meinung da war ja gespinst
eigentlich sein du spinnst sag mal du
spinnst eigentlich ein bisschen nein du
spinnst du hast nämlich keine balance du
siehst nicht okay hier ist was passiert
da ist nichts passiert es ist nämlich
nichts passiert es ist nichts passiert
es ist nämlich nichts passiert du
schwachkopf schwachkopf was man auf
passt mal auf mein auto
er kostet so viel wie du wahrscheinlich
in einem jahr verdienst und ein kratzer
in meinem auto kostet so viel wie du in
einem monat verdienen das stimmt und jan
bezahlt ich sag dir was überraschen
lassen es gibt keinen kratzer
also ich sehe hier keinen schaden
ich sehe einen kratzer an einen auto
aber an dein leben die wir trotz sein
ich will deinen finger zeiten er wurde
den kratzer neueste schaden
es ist nichts zu sehen nicht einmal
einen kratzer vom frühjahr das immer ich
bin du spinnst du bist ein richtiger
spinne du bist ein richtiger spinner
richtiger schwachkopf
ja du schwach es gibt ein
ist der schaden westufer der schaden ist
hier gehirn stand weißt du wo der
schaden ist hier gehirnschaden der
schaden ist in bei dir dein gehirn
gehirn schauen dass das das ist das
problem das wir islam
ich hoffe dass die polizei gegeben hat
um christa 1 aus dem hause
sag mal du kriegst gleich eins aufs maul
und wenn es möglich ist werde ich mal
den finger auch werden im mal deinen
finger runter ich werde dich immer beide
finger und ich werde dich verklagen
ich werde dich verklagen
dass du meine zeit ja verklagt mich mal
wieder wissen die prinzessin und einem
fenster meine kinder mögen dass die
ersten kratzer da drehst du hier hast du
ein gehirn kratzen
es ist lächerlich leicht haben die
polizei gott sei dank war um gut finden
danke sehr
ok jetzt seid ihr dran wir wollen von
euch wissen wer hat sich besser
geschlagen im streit emanuel auf der
linken seite von your daily german dot
com oder janiszewski von sind bloß lab
wir freuen uns auf eure ich freuen uns
auf eure meinung und wenn ihr übrigens
mal deutsch lernen wollt und richtig
alles verstehen will was die deutsche
grammatik angeht dann seid ihr war
einmal richtig denn er hat alles sehr
präzise erklärt präziser geht es gar
nicht mehr geht mal auf your daily
german dot com
länger geht es auch nicht tschüss dann
bis zur nächsten woche
ja wenn man länger geht es auch nicht
oder was ist was du arsch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]